the important thing
and the young at heart there's
the antique toys museum
a world of museums to satisfy even the most
avid collectors the fire engines museum
the maritime history museum [Music]
here outside the chinese art museum is one of
the few ceremonial dragons displayed in america
the philadelphia museum of art is one of
the great art centers of the world [Music]
10 acres of space 100 000 works of art
and not all of the art in philadelphia
is in museums or galleries
almost every time you turn a corner
there's a fountain or a statue or a mural
or a piece of sculpture philadelphia puts
it all together for a more beautiful city
learning has been part of the
philadelphia scene for over 200 years
the first university in america
was the university of pennsylvania
founded by benjamin franklin in 1751
but the university of pennsylvania
is just one of 33 centers of
higher education in philadelphia
haverford villanova temple bryn
mawr lasalle drexel and st joseph's
just a few of a complex of colleges more
here than in any other city in the nation
in medical education philadelphia
pioneers in both research and treatment
one out of every five american
doctors is a graduate of one
of philadelphia's six medical schools [Music]
so much technological research
is done in philadelphia
a lot of people think that
the words were invented here